hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video und zwar habe ich im internet sind
übels krasses neues corp spiel entdeckt
wo ich mir einfach gedacht hat dafür
brauche ich unbedingt ein partner mit
dem ich das zusammen aufnehmen kann
deswegen passt es perfekt das einfach
vor ein paar tagen der nachbarin zu mir
zugezogen ist und die habe ich einfach
mal eingeladen
die sollte gleich vorbei kommen dann
werde ich mit ihr zusammen dieses spiel
aufnehmen und das ist quasi das was wir
heute zusammen acht nicht schon da wo du
hast du bist tatsächlich du siehst
entstehen ganz anders aus setze ich mir
das irgendwie vorgestellt habe willst du
vielleicht etwas trinken irgendwas essen
irgendwas okay so wie du wie du was
dank an amazon prime dass wir dieses
coole video auf die beine stellen
konnten wenn es euch genauso gefallen
hat wie mir würde ich mich über einen
daumen hoch von euch freuen
vier walking dead gibt's jetzt exklusiv
die zweite staffel auf amazon prime
anzuschauen das heißt wenn jeder noch
kein mitglied seit kann ich euch nur das
30 tägige probeabo dort empfehlen packt
euch auch unbedingt 4 auf die watchlist
und dann würde ich sagen sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder ciao